the time flies when you're doing what
you love and tonight is the sixth
anniversary of the of Tucker Carlson
tonight this show I'm so honored to be
here on Tucker's behalf and to
congratulate him on the great success
that he's seen over the years and to say
thank you to all of you who are choosing
to spend your time here with us
now I'm sure that Tucker's supporters
and detractors alike cannot deny that
Tucker is carrying out exactly what he
promised to do
what's the show going to be about you
can judge for yourself but here's the
basic theme of it people in power tend
to lie not because they want to but
because they can't help themselves
that's human nature the more power
people have the bigger the temptation to
misuse it the Press is supposed to be
the Watchdog against all of this and it
worked fine for a couple of centuries
then the Press decide they had more
Uncommon with certain politicians than
with readers or viewers and that's when
it fell apart We're Gonna Get Back to
Basics here we're gonna hold the
powerful accountable Pierce pompocity
translate double speak Mock smugness and
barbecue nonsense every night
and that's about it for us tonight of
course tune in each night right here at
eight o'clock to the show that is the
sworn enemy of lying papacity smugness
and groupthink